[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the brady
neighborhood we are standing here with
maureen mccormick i am losing my mind
just like michelle is yeah marcia brain
no stop stop we are so excited to be
here for the first time in years all the
brave kids have come together and we are
here to hang with them here's the story
the actors behind Greg Marcia pieter-jan
Bobby and Cindy all came together today
how long has it been though since all
six of you kids have been together I
they're saying 15 years to me it seems
like maybe it was 20 but you know it's
been a really really long time and how
does it feel to see everybody again like
incredible it's surreal
but it's it's thrilling because I know
how we are yeah we picked right up where
we left off we've always been really
close we get along far better than
within real family yeah of course that's
because we don't have to share one
bathroom one thing I noticed is that we
just fall right back into it like we
like we always have fortunately we've
all remained friends throughout all of
these years so what's behind the reunion
hgtv just broke ground on its upcoming
project called a very brainy renovation
actually this la area home was just used
for the show's exterior shots but get
this the network wants to remodel the
inside to match what it looked like on
TV this was the first time you ever
stepped foot through that door today
yeah yeah how does that happen
honestly well because we were on stage
five at the Paramount live right you
know we didn't really even know about
this we just saw an exterior that was on
you know every episode today was the
first day you actually went inside yeah
none of us have ever gone in I've been
inside now for a couple hours and it's
uh it's it's cool none of us knew or
worked at this house it literally
doesn't resemble this the set at all now
here's some quick Brady House history
the three bedroom three
property is just under 2,500 square feet
it was first purchased back in 1973 for
sixty one thousand dollars and this year
it just went on the market for 1.88
million I want to buy this house in
sinks Lance Bass wanted to buy it and
turn it into a very Brady shrine but
HGTV outbid him paying 3.5 million
Maurine actually wanted to own it I feel
like no one could love it the way I
could just because of like the memories
and when we would go upstairs on the
show we would all huddle and so we'd
like flirt up there like I did HGTV's
biggest stars are here and as we said
the network's goal is to match the
interior what we all saw on TV how are
you going to change this house this is a
split-level home The Brady Bunch house
was a two-story yes so we are not going
to change the look of the front of the
house but when you're inside it will be
two-story with the stairs how is it Joe
is that how's that possible
HGTV hasn't said what they'll do with
the house once complete but it plans to
add 2,000 square feet to the homes
original footprint by summer HGTV was
busy filming a very Brady renovation
today Lance Bass will be involved it
will air in September of 2019 now next
year also marks 50 years since the Brady
Bunch premiered and today we are missing
quite a few Brady family members it's
old house smells fine I do wonder what
Robert and in Florence would think of
this today I think they would be very
proud of what we're doing here
they're all up there together yeah and I
just think they're smiling down on us
three amazing people all three are
missing today but you know Alice would
want to be in that kitchen helping
design telling them where to put her
appliances mr. Brady was an architect
Mrs Brady would have wanted him to be in
it yes come on oh this is kismet
[Music]